the anechoic chamber is a test lab for
doing acoustic testing
it's a chamber within a chamber within a
chamber
that's steve i'm steve orfield the
founder of orfield laboratories in
minneapolis and we're talking about what
it feels like to sit in one of the
quietest rooms on earth
an anaconic chamber is a room that
absorbs sound
so it's quiet when we
put subjects in the anechoic chamber we
sit them in a chair and we turn off the
lights
it turns out that the only noises you'd
hear in there are noises that come from
inside your own body right away you'll
usually hear the sounds of your ears
buzzing
you'll start to hear the joints in your
arms and in your legs
like the sound of rubbing two pieces of
wood together
you'll clearly hear your heart beating
kind of a
boom
the flow of the air into your lungs
and sounds from inside your body that
you might have heard outside the chamber
are suddenly so much louder any noise
that would be startling outside the
chamber would be 16 times the startling
inside the chamber noises like your
stomach growling
or your knuckles cracking
people don't last that long inside
maybe an hour and 15 minutes and that's
mainly because of one of two reasons
some people find that very relaxing
and some people find that
fearful or claustrophobic
one person's peace and quiet is
another's personal nightmare